oh yeah do you like the Pierce deal I do
I do
yes yeah oh yeah
bore on the floor hey it's a game in the
corner over there stand there go go go
go go all right Tom me yeah Bob Pierce
yeah well that's his love no factors and
but yes I personally I like like boar on
the floor over there
Jerry stand up Dan up Pierce well
actually I to be perfectly honest I've
I've had a few doubts honest
you see everybody do you see honesty
Greg stand up did you get any orders
from my brother the conscience
of the prairies me yeah don't yeah I
could I've had some doubts too Oh
doubter over there but the rules are
that you're spared if you tell the truth
and I just told you the truth oh there
are rules
how did you know something great there
are no rules okay
Roman I like it for real dad I win the
up okay Kendall took a call from
the biographer we all got a call room
okay yes but you see he seemed like he
wanted to actually talk to her to smoke
you out for dad what
you why do you get to smoke me out
I'm smoking you out what did you tell us
about your mystery call of the phone
call uh yeah it was Frank he meant to
call you he wants to know if the planet
overthrew dad is still happening someone
spiked Pierce what's one of you boys did
it Tom yes sit on the floor it's fun
seriously that's a gamebore on the floor
I really I feel get down war on the
floor boar on the floor candle ring the
troops poured on the floor wreck on the
floorboard
the would I know Greg you think I
have a rational explanation for this
[Applause]
point for your sausages biggie I called
Jesus Christ wait for your sister's Tom
my point
no no no half-hearted I I worked I on
the count of three the last piggy to eat
a sausage is the mole that doesn't seem
like a very good system who spoke to
pencil Hey crawl in a circle and close
your eyes
three Greg oink
[Music]
[Applause]
my sausage to f'ing slow I'll get you a
boobie price eat up piggies I believe he
said eat up piggies I want to see you
little piggy eat eat it in Timna
fication serious holding phone
what are you hiding nothing give me my
phone
what are you serious my coat my
coat is very slowly what dick
okay got it alright happy there's
nothing in there
you